Rachel's busy getting into Marvel
superhero universe playing Benedict
Cumberbatch's love interest in Doctor
Strange for me
he's got the manly stuff going on and
looks so good in that cloak I stood in
front of the mirror for the first time
with the Cape but a fitting it was a
really sort of giggly giddy childish
moment I just don't like gonna sign my
cheek thing a superhero and you are Wow
just one like Adele with the rejected
opening weekend of 75 million dollars
the movies getting a lot of buzz but
female fans are already crushing on the
Sherlock star one fan tweeted sometimes
when I'm sad I picture a shirtless
Benedict Cumberbatch slowly eating an
apple fritter try it and some women just
want to believe Benedict's wife and baby
are PR stunts most people know that I'm
married so that's it and not just
married you're also daddy strange yes
it's amazing that he can cope with
recognizing me with all this sort of a
danse of dr. Stephen strange and see but
somewhere underneath there is the daddy
he's so putting him to bed or wake him
up in the morning